when we first started the insurance
company
I I recruited a a husband and wife
wife's name was Diana and she sat me
down it's December 31st of
2010. it's 4 50. a guy's coming to do
for me to sign a contract to take over a
lease in Woodland Hills at the Warner
Center Marriott and she says I I want to
come work with you but you seem like
you're a little bit too aggressive and
I'm worried that you know the insurance
company is going to have challenges
because of the finances that you're
going to have some reckless spending
that's going to cost the company to go
out of business
and I look at it I'm like that's a fair
concern I said but the part that you
don't know and the only way I can tell
you is that there's a lot of things I'm
very frugal with which allows me to make
the tougher decisions when we need money
right company starts
do you know in the history of the
insurance company I was never the
highest paid guy in the company I've
never been the highest paid guy in the
company okay never I've been including
value payment I'm not the highest paid
guy in the company highest paid salary
I'm not in the company right
but what we did is we took the money and
we stayed very paranoid for example till
today
if I have to pay AV comes and says to us
80 000 is the bid and you know typically
people who are taking the bid aquapets
eighty thousand dollars I'm like I'm not
paying eighty thousand dollars let me
see the bid no go back to them for sixty
two thousand dollars we settle that
sixty five thousand dollars we just say
fifteen thousand dollars now somebody
may say who cares about that fifteen
thousand dollars it's fifteen thousand
dollars right yeah well you know here's
how we have to go this is all it is I
said you sure this is how much the
cameras yes and I'll go online so the
other day guys coming to set up the
internet system at our house because we
want to watch the fights in the Cabana
in the back instead of so we can smoke
the cigars and I'm setting it up so it's
gonna cost you 130 000 oh really yeah
what's your coupon you got I'm on the
zoom with them and I'm going pricing at
all these elephant myself and I'm
looking I said why are you charging me
this much and why are you charging me
this much three of the things I was able
to save four or five thousand dollars
but one of the things I I uh he gets it
cheaper than I do for wholesale well I
looked at wholesalers you notice I can
get it cheaper than you I said Fair
that's fine but I need you to lower
these to this anyways the whole thing
ended up being fifty nine thousand
dollars wow to get internet set up in
the background what was the initial
quote 100 something or some thousand but
we have the structure where we look at
three different offers on anything we
buy no matter what we do I don't think
our government is paranoid enough with
this debt I don't think the American
people are paranoid I don't think a lot
of CEOs today unfortunately 500 are
paranoid I don't think a lot of people
who are saying just take the vaccine or
just take this I don't think enough
people are apparent how much research do
we have on the I think too many people
have become like ah it's okay no man no
you got a wife you got a husband you got
kids you need you're the leader of the
pack you need to be a little bit
hesitant about what's going on do your
own research before you jumped in
conclusion with everything we've become
a little bit too look yeah okay uh-huh
yeah no no I don't know I don't know
what's going on with this I don't know
what's going on with the mortgage side
so we need to be a little bit more from
that perspective unless if you're the
type of a person my dad told me
something we had a a uncle named Albert
favorite uncle we had
he would come Sundays and he only wanted
to watch one show on Sundays do you know
the story or no he would come to my
house doesn't speak any English Okay a
Syrian guy okay Albert okay the only guy
that would give me a hundred dollars for
my birthday really every birthday and I
love him for it I eventually I took him
to a cruise in uh Caribbean with my dad
I said listen for every hundred dollars
you just want to meet I'm flying you out
we're gonna have a blast you have done
so much for me I love you he's in uh
he's in the hospital you just gotta you
know I love Albert family's special
family they changed my life but uh one
day my he comes and Albert comes in on
Sundays he says I said Albert the usual
yeah put it I want to watch it in
Assyrian he wanted to watch Kings of
Comedy because he wanted to watch Bernie
Mac wow he's watched a Bernie Mac from
Kings of Comedy if I tell you 100 times
that's a small number I said do you know
what he just said he says no two four of
a six-year-old God help me babysit these
[ __ ] so we would watch this not
a bad birdie so then he says to me he
says the two-year-old she the shepherd
for the devil whatever the two-year-old
said I know the whole thing because of
Albert because I've watched this party
Max thing so many times here's the point
I'm scared of you [ __ ]
so my dad sits me down and we're in the
kitchen it says look at Albert
and he says what about it he says just
look at him look how happy he is he says
he says that's the happiest person I
know in my life so look at him he says
be very careful reading these books I
said why he says because the moment you
have too much knowledge you're gonna
lose the innocence of being happy
because you know nothing
that was Albert so the point you have to
choose in life unless if you just want
to live a innocent happy life that
you're just chilling kicking and not
giving a [ __ ] about he couldn't even
know you asking what the Dow Jones is
he's gonna think it's a lady next story
hell down I said hello you know but the
point is if you choose to really pick up
a book and read you can enter a world us
right damn I better kind of learn to
make some adjustments but if you just
want to live a life like Albert dude
more power to you every family needs an
Albert so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here